[Music]
earlier today at the UN the Egyptian
president well he addressed the United
Nations yesterday i sat down with
president el-sisi to talk about how his
country is helping to fight radical
Islamic terrorism and much more I think
you'll find this interesting watch this
mr. president it's a great honor to have
you welcome vision to States a pleasure
to me they give it away thank you you
took one of the more courageous stands
I'd ever seen on the world stage as it
relates to radical Islam and I want to
remind our audience what you said and
you gave a speech and it was translated
and you were talking about the Islamic
world and the destruction of the rest of
the world and you said you raised the
question you said is it possible that
1.6 billion Muslims should want to kill
the rest of the world's inhabitants that
is 7 billion so that they themselves may
live impossible and then you said Islam
needs a religious revolution and I want
you to go into that further explain in
the new quick typically I was talking
about Allah movie our false ideas that
misrepresent I was talking about the
Dean such sets of ideologies that can be
adopted by some number which led to what
we can see around in this world now
because terrorism and extremism that we
say practiced by some extremist
organizations when we talk about
rectifying the religious rhetoric it
means that we want to filter the full
side neurology and the misconceptions of
of those who follow it so that we don't
see what we see happening around us in
this city I grew up in New York I've
lived around the rest of the United
States in this city
we lost 3,000 people
and it led to a big war on terror does
the world the people of this world need
to unite against modern-day evil that is
radical as well would you like to see
that the extremist specific ideology
it's not the only thing yes the
extremist ideology extremist
organizations as well we need to
confront those Islamic world community
and we need to stand from the
comprehensive strategy against these and
it's not confined to military security
confrontation comprehensive one with a
lot of other components economic social
cultural in addition to the security and
the military are components of this
confrontation when you indoctrinate
children into believing they are doing
the work of a creator of Allah whatever
the religion into believing that when
they kill innocence innocent men women
and children how is it possible that you
get to the root cause of it
and one of the things that I liked about
your speech is you address the address
the radicalism head-on that's what was
courageous I think there has been a
timidity a coward a coward Asst almost
when it comes to say radical Islamic
terror in this country people that say
radical Islamic terrorism are criticized
does that surprise you the criticism
indifference not normal with any idea so
the idea is has already been proposed or
is now being proposed but let me tell
you that I want you to imagine this if
one in 1,000 people from the 1.6 billion
Muslims becomes radicalized how many
radicalized people will be in the world
1 million
thousand and this is a four number but
let me explain here one thing that we
don't want to tarnish lose the whole
Muslims with one brush because of the
lesson now practices of some extremists
again I'm saying the confrontation
cannot be confined to New York of the
United States but we in our in our part
of the world has borne the brunt of this
extremism and terrorism and for many
years not only for the last decade we
are that's true but most people who pay
the highest price for the extremists in
the world that is true more Muslims have
been killed by radicalized Muslims than
any other group I concede the point you
yourself had to take military action
with the death of 21 Coptic Egyptian
Christians dealing with Isis in Libya at
the time and you took strong military
steps so it would be good in my view if
the world would recognize the radicalism
and confront it there sorry I want to
say that this was the first time when we
deployed our troops outside the
territory of Egypt to attack the
slaughter took place in Egypt as a
responsible leadership for the whole
nation
couldn't just that it had sleep at night
or mess that night without retaliating
you took it a step further your country
for example recognizes that the Muslim
Brotherhood you've designated it I agree
with you as a terrorist organization you
have asked the United States to
similarly designate this a terror
organization but there's been resistance
in the United States like there was
resistance to identifying radical
Islamists why do you think there's this
resistance to just identify those people
that would commit evil in our time
against innocent men women and children
a lesson with the head of the United
States is our great country and it's the
superpower in the world it has different
shades of ideologies and the United
States has its own perspectives that we
respect maybe it takes more time on the
part of the United States until they
recognize that the extremist
organizations have a bad impact not only
in the United States but on the whole
world and the United States is
responsible not only for the safety and
well-being of Americans but for the
whole world
and I'm asking the people to ponder at
the extremism and it's ideology and
stand unified as well Adam whatever the
names are Haram - service Boko Haram
these are different names of the same
entity